PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
This'll be the last video where
we do an optimization problem.
And this one's a little bit
different than the other two.
So I'm going to give
you the problem now.
The problem is the following--
a cylinder has a fixed volume.
What ratio between radius and
height minimizes surface area?
Before I give you time
to think about that,
I'm going to remind you of
the two formulas for volume
and surface area of a cylinder.
So volume of a cylinder
is pi r squared h.
And surface area is 2*pi
r squared plus 2*pi*r*h.
So with that information,
I'll give you
some time to work on this
problem and then I'll be back.
Welcome back.
OK, what we're doing,
again, is we're
trying to solve an
optimization problem.
And so we know now the
constraint equation,
it's a little different
than the other situations
because the
constraint equation is
just we're told that
there's a fixed volume
but we're not told what it is.
That actually will not change
how we work on this problem,
but it does change the kind
of answer I can ask of you.
And notice the
answer I ask is not
about exact values
for radius and height,
but what ratio between them
will minimize surface area.
So this is, you'll
see at the end,
things will look a
little different.
But ultimately we still have
our optimizing equation,
which is surface area.
And we still have our constraint
equation, which is volume.
So again, we're going
to do what we always do.
We're going to take our
optimization equation
and use our constraint equation
to get rid of a variable
so that we can write
the right-hand side here
in terms of one variable.
Let me point out V is
not a variable here.
V is a constant because
the volume is fixed.
So when you see V,
it's not a variable.
It's a constant.
So what do I do?
Let me write-- first, let me
write surface area in terms
of just a function of r.
And I'm going to do something
a little tricky which maybe you
didn't think of doing,
but ultimately you
should end up with the same
answer once you've simplified.
Notice that this
term has a pi*r*h.
This term also has a pi*r*h.
In fact, I can rewrite the
volume equation as V over r is
equal to pi*r*h.
So what I'm going to do is take
that pi*r*h here and replace it
by a V over r.
Now again, you might
not have done this.
You should ultimately
get the same answer
that I do when we're finished.
And even sooner, probably
some simplification
would be the same.
The only thing I've done here
is I've simplified right away.
So by looking at the problem
and kind of pulling back
from the problem
I see, oh, there's
something here
that looks exactly
like something over here.
So I just want to
point that out.
That it's not wrong to
just substitute for h,
but it's maybe a little faster.
So now the new surface area
equation becomes 2*pi r squared
plus 2V over r.
So now we have everything in
terms of r, because again, V
is a constant.
Now let me point
out what happens.
When r goes to infinity
this term goes to 0,
but this term goes to infinity.
So as r gets very large surface
area is getting very large.
As r goes to 0 this
term goes to 0,
but this term goes to infinity.
V is fixed, and when r goes
to 0 this term blows up.
So when r gets as small as we
allow or as large as we allow,
either way, surface area
is going to be getting big.
So where this-- where
surface area has
a derivative with
respect to radius
it's going to have
to be a minimum.
So we don't have to check
any more-- now we've
checked sort of the what's
happening towards the boundary
at the extreme values of r.
So now we can, now we can
actually solve the problem.
Well, what do we do?
We're using our
optimization equation.
We want to take a derivative
and set it equal to 0
and find what value
for r gives that.
But again, let me point out
one more time that in the end
I'm asking for a ratio
between radius and height.
So I'm not going to get
all the way to where
I have r equals something.
You'll see I'm going
to do another trick.
But let me first take
the derivative I need.
Surface area prime, this is
derivative with respect to r.
I have 2*pi r squared.
That derivative with
respect to r is 4*pi*r.
And this derivative with respect
to r, I'm going to keep the 2V,
and the denominator 1 over r,
its derivative is negative 1
over r squared.
So I'm going to have 4*pi*r for
the first term and then minus
2V over r squared.
If I set this equal to 0,
the derivative equal to 0,
and solve, I get to 2V over
r squared is equal to 4*pi*r,
which is the same as-- going
to put it on this side--
r cubed is equal to 2*pi
over V. Let's just check.
If I multiply both sides by
r squared, divide by 4*pi--
oh, I did it backwards.
I think it should
actually be pi over 2V.
Let me double check that
all my signs are correct.
That's r cubed, divide by
4*pi, I should get pi over 2V.
I should not.
I've been told from the
audience I made a mistake.
Sometimes you'll see when you're
at the board and on video,
scary things can happen.
2V-- oh.
Multiply through by
r, I get r cubed.
Oh, I have the 2V
in the numerator.
I apologize.
The 2V is in the numerator,
the 4*pi is in the denominator.
So I get V over 2*pi.
Does that look better, audience?
The audience tells
me that looks better.
OK.
So here I am.
I have r cubed is
equal to V over 2*pi.
Now, if I wanted to I could
take the cube root of both sides
and get r explicitly
in terms of V and 2*pi.
V is a constant, pi is a
constant, I would be done.
But I didn't ask for
what r actually is.
I asked for a ratio.
So let's make this
problem simpler.
All I need in the end
is r divided by h.
Let's go back to
a formula we have
and see if we can figure out
a way to get r divided by h.
Look at this formula for
V. It has an r squared
and it has an h.
So if I divide by r
squared h on this side,
I'll end up with an r over h.
Hopefully you buy that.
I'm going to even write it out.
I'm going to take r cubed
and divide it by r squared h.
That in the end, is r over h.
Let's go back here look
at what that equals.
r squared h is
equal to V over pi.
Right?
r squared h is
equal to V over pi.
So I can divide this side
by r squared h and divide
this side by V over pi
and it's the same thing.
Which is, by the
way, the same thing
as multiplying by
pi over V. Right?
So I can multiply this side by
pi over V, and what do I get?
I get the V's divide out, the
pi's divided by-- divide out,
and I get 1/2.
So the result is that the
ratio between radius and height
should be 1 to 2.
Let me one more time explain
what we were doing here.
In the end, the
answer, the question
just asks, what is the ratio
between radius and height
that minimizes surface area?
And I had an r cubed, I
wanted to get r divided by h.
So I divided by two r's--
I divided by r squared--
and then h again.
But r squared h is V over pi,
so if I divide by r squared h
I'm dividing by V over pi.
So I can do on the
right-hand side
the same thing that I do on the
left-- I divided by V over pi,
which is multiplying by pi
over V. The pi's divide out,
the V's divide out,
and I'm left with 1/2.
And so this was an optimization
problem where the constraint
equation did not have a
number in it, but it did have,
it did have a fixed constant.
So I couldn't ask you for an
exact value for the radius
and an exact value
for the height,
but I could ask you
for how they relate.
And that's ultimately
what I did.
And I think that's
where we'll stop.